قبل مباراته يوغسلافيه الاولى امام
البرازيل في مونديال الاوروغواي عام 30
سال صحفي المدرب اليوغسلافي بوسكو
سيمونوفيتش عن حقيقه عدم خوض لاعبيه اي
تدريبات منذ وصولهم لمونتيفديو فكان رده
وفقا لما نقلت صحيفه لناسيون الارجنتيني
انا لاعبيه ليس محترفين وليس لديهم اي
دافع للتضحيه ويحبون التمرد على التدريبات
وان لعبهم لن يختلف كثيرا بلمس الكره اكثر
من مره او اداء تدريبات الضغط التي لا
تحققه سيوا الزياده في الصلابه الجسديه
ويبدو ان وجهه نظر الرجل كانت صحيحه بشكل
او باخر وتتناسب مع مقاييس تلك الفتره فقد
قدمت يوغسلافيا اداء طيبا في البطوله
فتصدرت مجموعتها بانتصارها على البرازيل
بهدفين بهدف وعلى بوليا برباعيه نظيفه قبل
ان تسقط في نصف نهائي امام الاوروجواي
البلد المضيف وحامل اللقب تلك النسخه
بنتيجه سته اهداف